how's it going pretty good Etho how are
you pretty good you
Muslim alhamdulillah all right yeah does
Etho stand for
Ethiopian yes sir oh okay cool cool cool
so tell me all civilization started okay
so what do you think the inil is yeah go
ahead well I mean let me just say this
real quick
mind so you've been debating it pretty
much all day long it's you put down job
and I'm really surprised why you're not
a Muslim by now really yeah because uh
everything that I hear and I've been
following you and then uh you just deny
the
truth right in front of you and you're
rejecting
Islam and when the truth right in front
of you being explained to you M you
can't really the argument with any
Muslim pretty
much and uh but you are a denial that's
why you are okay you know what I I
respect that opinion can you tell me can
you tell me specifically I mean at least
to because you you said I do this all
the time I'm doing this all day I
haven't been able to get over with any
Muslims and any of on the arguments or
answers that they brought so what is an
answer to this question that I'm asking
today day because I've asked this I've
been asking this for a very long time
I've run into a bunch of them right I've
I've had a whole debate on it with John
Fontaine I went to hamza's well not
hamza's Den but I went on Muslim cowboys
live stream with Muslim Cowboy Hamza
ramsy um and others to discuss the
subject so I watch so what what what is
hold on what is what what is the answer
that was given to me on what the inil is
that I wasn't able to refute or that I
just deny that was a clear answer and I
was just in denial
about about
inel yeah the angel was uh sent to
Jesus the original book
okay right now
right go ahead yeah yeah okay so it's
it's it's a book that's given to Jesus
now every Muslim has told me this right
every Muslim has told me this but that
doesn't necessarily answer my question
because I'm I know that you believe that
the inil is a book given to Jesus I'm
asking what was that book you get what
I'm
saying what was it
yeah well I mean some of the message was
sent still you have it on the Bible some
of' been changed other and uh corrupted
it's still corrupted so if first really
agree with the Quran and then we can
accept it no problem but if it's again
it's the Quran and then we deny it okay
so you're saying that some of the inil
is in the Bible
today yes of course so Matthew Mark Luke
and John wrote some of the
inil now they're not angels I mean
the all those
disciples soal I think I think one of
them I don't which never met Jesus but
hold on because you said that the some
of theil is in the Bible that would be
Matthew Mark Luke and John so Matthew
Mark luk and John and when I said so you
so Matthew Mark luk and John wrote the
inel you said of course right so they
wrote they wrote the inal down at least
some of
it right I mean some of them they got
the teaching from Jesus be opponent
uhhuh some of
them was corrupted over time by the
church and by you maybe you said by
me still you know involving I mean the
corruption never stopped it's still
going you no I I hear you so Matthew
Mark Luke and John wrote down the NG
Okay cool so we have the we have the
NG Matthew Mark Lan John wrote it and
then so I'm I'm just I'm
just I'm just I'm just a little I'm I'm
a little lost why do you then say that
it's corrupted when you acknowledge that
Matthew Mark lugan John wrote it and we
have that we have what they wrote no
they don't you don't we don't have what
Matthew Mark lukan John wrote no you
don't what do we have what what you have
is named by them that they didn't write
thing oh the church the
church you know 300 years later is the
one who's you know so they can rule the
word you know by having the the the
Bible support their brutality I see yeah
they change it so they can for them to
rule all right do me this favor then can
you give me a verse that of the NG that
Matthew actually wrote what what's a
verse in the angel that that Matthew
actually wrote himself I I uh if I have
a time dude man I'll be reading my own
Quran I don't read the
Bible so are you just you just saying
stuff man I'm not saying you're talking
you're talking out of your
neck no I've been I've been watching a
lot of debate tell you the truth and uh
it's very it's very obvious
so you have so you have so you have
nothing what I mean what do you have
tell me no I'm I'm talking about you you
have nothing you have nothing to give me
or to offer me or to show me of what
you're saying myran my Quran in my
religion is very convincing for me is it
so I I don't have to look anywhere else
I got the true on my hand I I I
understand that you believe that uh it's
a diluted belief and this is why because
you have no substance of what you're
saying you're you're telling me things
that but you're but you're you're
walking on air and when I say okay so
just one second EO one second and so
when I so when I say okay I hear what
you're saying can you demonstrate or
show me what you're talking about like
can you show me um a particular passage
that Matthew wrote himself as opposed to
the passages that Matthew didn't write
that's ma that's has Matthew name on it
you know and you say well you know what
actually I don't have time you know if I
had time I'd be reading my Quran I don't
read your Bible that that's what you
that's what you tell me but then but
then you wantan hold on let me finish it
let me finish it but then when I receive
answers like what you gave because
you're not the only one who's answered
like this trust me when I receive
answers like the one you gave me I get
people like you that come up and say you
know what Avery you're you're being in
denial you've been giv answers to this
stuff and you're just in denial you you
can't you can't you can't even win an
argument against any of the Muslims
you're in denial what what am I supposed
to do
here okay so let me just asking you why
I'm coming from and tell you that your
Bible is corrupted I don't I don't I
don't care about that bro I know you
believe that I know you believe
that corrupt okay so then your Quran is
confirming corrupted books
then right you said right yep so the
just to be clear the Quran and this has
been said before actually but I do have
to write this down again man every live
stream we get something we get something
said every live stream hold on I'm
getting my uh my notebook um and in my
notebook my 2025 notebook I write down
the crazy things that Muslims say for
the year and um why you say crazy
you know what why is it
crazy why is say crazy because when
because to
confir well to confirm something means
that you are attesting that the thing is
true right and then so you're saying
that the Quran confirmed or attested to
the truth of corrupted scripture if
scripture is corrupted then it's not
true but you're telling me that the
Quran is saying that corrupted scripture
is is true that's why it's crazy I I
mentioned that to you earlier dude I
mentioned to you that some of the
Bible if it's agreed with the Quran it's
not corrupted and some of them if it
disagree with Quran which you me been
added okay so that's just really easy to
understand I don't know why you you know
what it's crazy because you're actually
not the first person that said this this
year somebody named anas Islamic Apex he
was debating a Christian named black
doctor and he actually said that yes
Allah's confirming corrupted
scripture isn't that isn't that
amazing what's his name Etho one23 Tick
Tock
EO 123 on Tik Tok
all
right thanks thanks EO I got what I
needed from you all right let's see uh
let's see what else we got here guys man
this is uh W what a trip the Quran
confirms corrupted scriptures and he
also added onto that yeah of course of
course why is that
[Laughter]
crazy guys give an honor to
God just send blessings up towards
heaven that he has saved you and brought
you out of Darkness because you can
easily be the these people you can
easily be this you can be this we can
all be this we can all be stuck in
darkness and stuck in our ways and stuck
in our own foolishness professing to be
wise we can all be like this a lot of us
were until Jesus brought us out so let's
just take this moment to give glory to
the one Triune God who had mercy and
Grace upon us to Stow his love on us his
Tender Loving Care on us unconditionally
while we were still Sinners while we
were still in our foolishness thinking
we were wise thinking we were smart he
brought us to the light and made us new
and molded us into a new image thank you
Lord thank you Lord Jesus and we pray
that God brings these people out as well
we know that you know we can make fun
all the time and we we laugh at this
stuff but guys this is actually a it's
sad it's a real sad sickness this isn't
just about proving these people wrong or
you know showing how stupid Islam seems
this is like we we care about you guys
man and we want you guys to hear what
you're saying this isn't
right this isn't
right so we pray that God brings you
guys to the truth
man okay
hi hello you hear me yes okay hi welcome
so you wanted to answer to your question
right yes thank you for having me by the
way because you said okay just give me
give me 10 seconds okay
as we wait on him let me go ahead and
get a couple super chats in here where
did I leave off Manny bergo says Ali
dawa yeah that's Innovation but doesn't
take you out of
Islam uh sorry uh if it's okay can you
bring someone and then bring me back I I
just have something to do right now oh
okay so that's okay I look I I want to
stay okay just bring someone now and I
will come after him okay all right yeah
I'll leave you on stage you can just
unmute when you're ready all right okay
okay thank you all
right thank you so much for the super
sticker
KO okay I read those
already let's see you only need two more
no I don't guys I do not guys I don't
know what metrics you you guys are
using but on
YouTube my current subscriber
count where's the YouTube button at my
current subscriber
count for those of you guys who think
that you know more than me on my own
channel my current subscriber
count is
that's my current subscriber count
okay I don't know what y'all are using
or seeing I do not have 300K yet we will
soon though Lord willing we will
soon we'll be right there we'll be right
now all
right okay um all right next guess nahid
how you
doing nah nah I'm back
oh okay sorry n I'll you you'll be right
after mahm okay I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry
hi uh first thank you for having me here
uh second your question was uh according
to the Muslim Paradigm what is the inil
right no not according to the Muslim
Paradigm just objectively what is the
inil uh okay the inil is a revelation
that has been given to Jesus
Christ um it is also mentioned in the
bible uh that he went in Galilee and
preached the gospel
right are you following me yes say I was
reading the comment I'm sorry say say
that again okay I said that it's a
revelation that has been given to Jesus
Christ peace be upon him just like the
Torah has been given to Moses for
example uh it uh there has it was also
mentioned in the Bible that uh Jesus
went in Galilee and preached the gospel
in multiple verses so uh what what what
why do we say that the gospels that you
have right now is not the Gospel of
Jesus it's just because uh they are
first of all four the Gospel of Jesus is
just
one uh also they are very different from
each other not not in not completely
different they have many similarities
but for example they are different the
number of words different number of
chapters uh different maybe some events
here not there you know so they are not
identical the Gospel of Jesus is just
one gospel just one
book are you following me
yes okay um so does that answer your
question
or no okay you just you you told me what
the gospel is not you didn't tell me
what it is yeah uh so it it should be
something similar to the Torah for
example uh it's uh like a list of
commands it's like uh uh do this don't
do that this happened this didn't happen
uh in the past for example uh for
example it uh it would be like the Ten
Commandments for example you know
okay these comments are killing me yeah
guys I kind of zoned for a second but
yeah all right um okay so let's deal
with the the first objection here about
okay what I have are four when the
Gospel of Jesus is one
and in fact what I have is not four
different gospels brother what we what I
have is one gospel that's written by
four Witnesses four testimonies of the
Gospel of Jesus okay so it's all one
gospel just four Witnesses Matthew Mark
and John yeah but you wouldn't say they
are the exact same right they are it's
the exact same gospel just toed from the
different angles yeah I mean I mean the
content is not 100%
exact
right what do you for example okay okay
for example the Torah like every Jew has
the same Torah
right uh
sure uh the Torah when it was given to
Moses Christi every every Christian has
the same go that's not what I meant uh
what I meant is for example when Moses
was given the Torah a lot of people
recorded it but everyone recorded the
same
Torah they they didn't record the Torah
Accord according to Elijah for example
or the Torah according to Aaron or the
Torah they recorded the
Torah okay how many books is in the
Torah um I think there are five books
right mhm but is the Torah singular or
plural um the word singular singular
because it was one right so even though
the Torah is one right one word singular
yet it has it's a multiplicity of books
so the gospel the Ino
singular can be a multiplicity of books
uh I understand but there is a very
important distinction here what is it uh
is that uh the books of the Torah speak
about different subjects not the same
subject the books of the Torah take talk
about different subjects what are you
talking about uh like for example
Genesis talks about
creation um other books might talk about
laws other books might talk about
history right yeah all in these are
different subjects in the Torah this is
comparable in the New Testament with
with for example uh the gospels versus
what Paul wrote or the revelations or in
the in the gospel you have different
subjects that are that are uh
covered but it it's all about
Jesus yes that's what the gospel is it's
the Gospel of Jesus and Jesus covers a
multitude of
subjects w
okay let let me reintroduce my idea
again
okay the four gospels speak about the
same time
frame with almost the same
events with the same
message but using different
words and different let's see
perspective points right the Quran does
that yeah the Quran does that but the
Quran claims it's only from one
source which would mean it's more of a
problem if the Quran does that yet it's
supposed to be from One Source One
witness yet in one place talking about
the same event in the same time and the
same story has different wordings
different things that are said and even
different characters in there from the
other event when it mentioned it the
first time that kind of would show an
issue there right as opposed to when you
have four Witnesses that's recording in
event you can have different details
mentioned in the accounts they're not
each other it's the full story but but
let's let's do a hypothetical for
example okay okay let's not do a
hypothetical uh there are many gospels
that have been not that were not added
to the Bible for example right there are
not many gospels that are not added to
the Bible you're the
gospels um we're always talking about
the Apocrypha and
the well talking about Gnostic Gospels
those are not forgeries those aren't
real
gospels um um the church decided that
I'm sorry the church was the one that
decided this yeah just like it was your
companions that decided the chapters in
the numbering of the chapters and the
ordering in your Quran yeah but they
didn't remove things from it right yes
they did they literally did U man burned
whole copies of the Quran uh he burned
copies from the Quran but he didn't he
didn't deleted from the minds for
example he he did he he rewrote he
rewrote the Quran he did not rewrite it
he compiled it he do you he rewrote from
the compile brother do you want me to
show you where it literally says he
rewrote it you want to see want to see
that and go ahead
okay sooner or later you gentlemen and
ladies in the faith um I'm sorry ladies
in humanity brothers and gentlemen and
ladies in ity will learn to trust me
when I say something I don't be talking
out the side of my neck man you know I'm
the shake
right you know that right you know I'm
the
shake you know that
right um no but go ahead you know that
look this is where it comes from man let
me actually show you it wasn't me that
said this actually this was a Muslim
listen listen to this it might be a
little low
but listen to
this
lot the
sound does it sound too low no no it's
uh it's doubling like I hear it twice e
oh it's echoing oh cause because I got
Tik Tok open yeah man this stuff this
stuff is annoying man we got to figure
this out but okay let me um let me do
this but anyway it was a Muslim saying
that Avery knows more things about Islam
than him than everybody that was on that
panel and then most Muslims in the
entire world that it wasn't me saying
that I was a Muslim talking with other
Muslims saying that they were uh having
a surviving God logic moment episode
two um all right let's
see all right so this is Saar 4987 I'm
just gonna go to the part that's
relevant okay
so uh right here
send us so utman talking to HSA he says
send us the manuscripts of the Quran so
that we may compile the quranic
materials in perfect copies and return
the manips to you okay so stop here
stop okay go ahead go ahead ordered
zabit Abdullah Bin
a s bin Alas and um and
Hasam thank
you go to rewrite the manuscripts in
perfect
copies so he rewrote he had the Quran
Rewritten uh
copied yes
Rewritten on yeah Rewritten doesn't mean
he he he changed the content it just
means he took what's written on for
example bones and wrote it on
paper but here it says he rewrote the
manuscripts in so-called perfect copies
and then watch what he did at the end
okay H then he burned the manuscripts
that that were gathered from the people
right I know this sent to every Muslim
Province one copy of what they had
copied and ordered that the other konic
material all other chonic material
whether written in fragmentor
manuscripts or whole copies be burned
yeah that's true so he
rewrote good so he had the Quran re
written and then burned the other copies
of the Quran whether they were fragments
or whole copies changed all all kinds of
stuff uh can you bring me the Hadith
again just so so I can look at in
Arabic maybe there is a fault in
Translation or something maybe you want
the
Arabic yeah because the yeah I want the
Arabic I think yeah tell me when tell me
when the
scroll uh can you go up a little bit
uh down down down
down down down down down more more more
yes stop it
here yeah the Arabic here
says here means they copied
it just the translations just wrote put
the word rewrite it just to make it
clear wait the word re Rewritten isn't
there no no it's not in the Arab
means
copied in Ms they copied in what MS m is
a is a like a new word for Quran it's
for know what that word so when when it
says here when it
says um you can take it to Google
Translate if you if you don't trust me
you know when it says here to rewrite
the manuscripts in
to rewrite the manuscript perfect copies
this whole sentence is just one word
which means
copy so they copied it in in muss it's
say in muss
yeah if we have if we have an Arabic
speaker that's uh that's their brother
take it to Google translate I'm not
asking you to trust
me I like I like to get you know Arabic
speakers to just come up and just show
it to me so I I'll have a I'll have an
Arabic speaker come and either confirm
or deny what you're saying but why it
right now to to Google
Translate because I don't want to
because Google Translate is imperfect it
be messing up a lot just take what the
the one word take it which one let's see
if if uh the last word on
the uh in the first on the first line
you have
here this
one oh sorry where I don't I don't see
the cursor yeah this one where Where It
Go all right so where where am I at on
the the first line yeah the last word
copy
it let's see if it changes
anything let's do this
if you want to copy the word after after
it also to make sure there is no extra
words that I didn't
translate look I'm not asking you to
trust me you know I will show
you so they copied
it yeah the word just ABD they copied it
into M isn't that rewriting
it they copy it they writing it
again yeah copy copy copy is to write
again but itop explicitly means that
they did not the content they just talk
what was written how how is content not
being changed how's content not being
changed if they burn the
others um because he didn't even see the
others you know what are you talking
about he had them burned what do you
mean he didn't see the others look look
at the time ofman uh the the Muslim
empire was stretching from uh almost
Constantinople until Yemen in the South
man only himself gathered the the the
manuscripts in Medina he couldn't reach
further than that he ordered so he
burned those other manuscripts in Medina
right in Medina he didn't burn
everything he just burn he burned some
and bur and buried others no he burned
every he he ordered that all of them be
burned yeah he ordered he ordered all of
them be burned but what he gathered
himself he didn't burn them all because
he some of them he just buried in in
good places you know that's why we have
some manuscripts today that were buried
not
burnt like the two pages in uh in in it
says that all quranic manuscripts
whether whole copies or fragments be
burned what are you talking about yeah
he ordered he ordered that but he when
he gathered himself he didn't burn what
he had on then why do you have different
content in your
qurans uh because the Quran because the
Quran was revealed on seven seven means
seven dialects some dialects contain
words that other di but you but you said
that the content is the same the content
is the same in thean Quran because all
theeven you just said brother listen to
what you're saying you just list I will
I will tell you I will tell you you just
said that the contents are is different
because there's seven different Kat
right yes okay so the content in your
qurans are
different yes but you have no problem
with that I will tell you why right now
go ahead tell me why it's tell me why
it's it's a problem can you just calm
down calm down not a problem when y'all
do it I'm just calm down calm down I'm
excited here okay okay I
I
the did not contain anys or dots or di
critics okay
you understand me I understand
everything you're saying how does this
answer what I'm
asking the dots and Di critics uh there
were dots at the time butman
purposefully didn't use them so his M
could include all the seven K How Does
it include all the seven that they would
be confused they don't know what it is I
will tell you because the difference
between all the Kat is only in the dots
and that's not true you have literally
have words that are there and words that
aren't what are you talking about like
what you okay so you have uh like uh in
I think it's 5724 in the Hopson warsh
what the word has haa in it in the uh in
the Hops version in the war it doesn't
5724 if I'm not mistaken that's
one the word h is not there I'm look I'm
looking at I'm looking it up right now 5
which which verse again sorry I'll show
it 572 24 57
house uh in half it contains ha let's
see
24 mhm how do I scroll over what the
heck yeah you all
right the word is not there in one the
word is there in
another
correct so how do you explain this stuff
if is if the contents are supposed to be
the same it's just diacritical marks
meaning you know the markings over the
the letters the dots the dashes those
will change how you say a word what the
word means but words are there one
second yeah words are there in some and
those same words are gone in
others one
second uh
yeah I don't
know and let me tell you this because I
want to be real with you I don't
necessarily think that this is a problem
with the Quran however for your position
it poses a problem because you're saying
if the contents within the gospel is
different and that's a problem well you
have contents within your qurans that
are different
and then that should be a problem for
you you the same reason why you're
rejecting the gospel that I have and the
style that it's in with four Witnesses
with different details different you
know content like that you should throw
away the Quran for the same
reason you get what I'm saying you got
to be consistent I I I see I see your
position okay I understand it um but uh
I okay first of all I think that the
word
H is just too insignificant you
know in in relation in relation to the
differences in the four gospels there
they are for example the the number of
chapters you know brother yeah you have
you have Matthew Mark Luke and John
preaching and relating the same gospel
with some having more details than
others they're not contradictory to each
other you put them all together it's
called harmonization you harmonize what
they all put together you get the full
picture of the Gospel that's what that
is that's why you have Mark Mark Cuts
straight to the Chase he doesn't really
give that much detail he cuts straight
to the chase as opposed to Luke whose
account is very detailed very structured
and same with Matthew right or John
who's you know his you know christology
is you know his the theology when it
comes to Jesus very detailed in that I
would say Mark is too but it's just
shorter you have different details same
gospel harmonize it all together you get
the full picture it's not a problem but
you just said that some of them are more
detailed than others right yep just like
some which one Jesus exactly
preach brother come on
now you you know what let me show you
another another way that you're being a
hypocrite okay if I were to show if I
were to show you matter of fact let's do
this let's just have fun okay maybe
maybe you might get it again if I show
you the the what you're doing from your
Quran
standpoint and we're g to see that it's
going to be cool when the Quran does it
but it's a problem when when the Bible
does it let's see um we open my Quran
up let's go to
let's go here let's go
19 Let's Go sir
Mariam
16 hold on let's go
further here it is so chapter 19 verse1
17 and had chosen seclusion from them
then we sent unto her our spirit The
Rook right m
it assumed for her the likeness of a
perfect man so the spirit appeared to
Mary right yeah and what did the spirit
do she said lo I seek
Refuge uh you know from you y y y he
said I am a messenger to of your Lord
that I may bestow on you a faultless son
I I I memorize this so good so you know
this so it's the spirit it's the spirit
that gave her the news that she is going
to give birth to a son
right okay but that's not the point the
point is if you are going to bring
another it should have either anra word
or a missing word no I'm G use the same
just use the same the same okay same
Quran same version same story different
details here
345 and remember when the Angels said
now we have Angels coming to Mary not
the spirit here but the Angels Came to
Mary oh Mary Lo Allah gives you glad
tides of a word from him whose name is
Messiah Jesus Son of Mary wait what I
thought it was the spirit that came to
Mary but the spirit is an
angel no where where where does the
Quran say that uh it says that the holy
spirit in the Quran states that the holy
spirit is Gabriel no it doesn't show me
where I will I will give me one second
okay
I'll just look up the
verse in the meantime while he gets that
because it's it's never gonna happen let
me go ahead and read a couple of super
chats it will happen
okay as soon as you get the verse
interrupt me I'm just going to go ahead
and read a couple super chats okay okay
okay go ahead all right uh we got
patriotic Z who says only the rich and
Nobles had last names we also have
Apostolic chains going back to the
apostles
exactly exactly Christ's life says sadly
David wood was just banned from Britain
in the video he posted about it he even
alluded that the government is anti-
anti-islam now Britain is slowly dying
so being
anti-islam Britain is against being
anti-islam that's pretty deep uh every I
found it you found it all right what
what's the ver 16 102
162 if you want to read the context you
wa it's okay I context let's just go
ahead and and get this over with we're
gonna see if it says if you want if you
want to see the whole context start from
98 if you want that's all good it's all
good so this verse says that the holy
spirit is Gabriel right H it says that
Theo the holy spirit is the one that
brought down the Quran and the one that
brought down the Quran is Gabriel wait a
second
where does this you told me you about to
show me that it says that the holy
spirit is
Gabriel so this doesn't say because look
look look look we add one plus one equal
two right I know your logic it says says
the Holy Spirit brought down the Quran
it says Gabriel brought down the Quran
or it says the Quran was brought down by
Gabriel
so
so all right so if you put 1 plus 1
equals two then the conclusion is is
that both the holy spirit and Gabriel
brought down the Quran right uh no they
are the same person where do it where
does it say
that see now let me show you why I'm
saying what I'm saying I'm going to give
you proof for for what I'm saying that
it's the Angel and the spirit that
brings down the Revelation
watch we're going to stay in the same
chapter I'm going to go to the
beginning chapter two
but you also have to know that we don't
only rely on the Quran right we have we
can hey you can use Hadith too so but
just pay attention to what I'm doing I'm
gonna use your same verse I'm sorry your
same chapter to show to prove my point
right that it's both the angels and the
spirit that come down with the
Revelation look this is chapter 16 verse
two okay 100 verses before he sends down
the angels with the spirit of his
command unto whom he will of his bondmen
warn mankind that there is no Allah save
me so keep your duty unto me so both the
angels and the spirit bring down the
revelation of
Allah so if you have a verse that says
wait wait wait wait wait
wait uh with here is is
not um okay in the Arabic
mhm
um is for example I say I can say that I
am fixing the chair with a hammer it
doesn't say the hammer is coming with me
I'm just using the hammer wait hold on a
second you you're you're fixing the
chair with the hammer so the chair is
different from the with from the hammer
right H yeah the chair is different from
the hammer yes so the angels are
different from the spirit
right uh yeah but they are not coming
together
they are coming together they're
together he sends down the angels with
the spirit of his command they come down
together okay so therefore the angels
are not the
spirit they're
different so when it says the Holy
Spirit brought down the Revelation and
then another verse says the angel
Gabriel brought down the Revelation both
of them together brought down the
Revelation it doesn't mean they're one
in the
they both together brought down the
Revelation uh okay so there's nothing in
the Quran that says that Gabriel or the
angel is the spirit so then why in 345
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait okay okay we we we can refer to the
Hadith to understand this verse all
right go take me there okay um so we
have the T of Abbas you know Abbas right
you said that you said you have a
Hadith uh it's aith from Ab Abbas is the
cousin of the Prophet so you're show me
a t and not a Hadith right
okay said
that here is the Revelation
itself okay the Torah for example so the
Angels come down with the Revelation
yeah who who is the
spirit the the word Spirit here means
revelation
no is is is not brother you you we we
both know that the word R means Spirit
right and it might have other meanings
this is Arabic this is Arabic we're
talking about come on let's not let's
not do this please this is how we spend
too much time I'm I'm not look look look
look I'm not doing this I I didn't come
with this opinion from myself this is so
the spirit is the Revelation
right it is not a spirit
it's means
Revelation it me
reation what does the word wah
mean no wah what does wahi
mean reation there you go what's the
word here right so it's
not what different words can give the
similar meaning right can you can you
agree can you agree that R means
Spirit but not exclusively can you so
you agree that it means Spirit okay so R
means no worries so the Angels come down
with the Rook the spirit or the spirit
who is the Revelation still doesn't help
you that the angels are different
they're distinct from the spirit or the
spirit who is the Revelation still not
the same Gabriel is not the spirit he's
not The Rook yeah so we're still in the
same box again again again
uh it the the angels have been known to
bring Revelation it's um sometimes the
Revelation is not exclusive to Angel
Gabriel but according to Hadith the
Quran itself is exclusive to Angel
Gabriel what you have to do here since
we
look hold on since the first attempt
failed yeah what is the reason here I
still I still have to explain this yes
you still have to explain this because I
still have to prove that angel Gabriel
is a is the spirit right
okay oh should I get back to the all
right yeah go back to the all right I'll
get back to the to the super chats let's
play our our little waiting music let's
put it on
low get way the
music all right ladies and gents as we
wait let's go ahead and get to our super
chats
here let's see here we got JJ who
says an honest Muslim musl is an
ex-muslim maybe Mahmud if he's honest
might be an ex Muslim
soon come on everybody let's do the
Muslim Shuffle y'all
stupid we got I sense a shuffle it's
crazy can anyone else smell what The
Chef is
cooking Fatar says umman had Mormon I'm
sorry umman had Momo's companion beaten
for not giving his version of that's
true he had IB Mas beaten up I found one
found it all right uh yeah let me just
get the number of the verse continue
reading just 10 more seconds I'm sorry
okay I was just excited okay
okay all right we got Rivers who says
since it's proven Jesus isn't a Muslim
it's time we claim back the other
prophets Moses Abraham Etc they can keep
though you know what
yes I'll do a I'll do a live on on if
Moses was a
Muslim yes we'll do that too uh Surah 26
verse 1
193 or
both what I I love I love those I love I
love 26 from
192 to 196 I love love that context it
talks about the Quran and being an
Arabic and how the previous scriptures
mention it it came down from
um um the
spirit let's
see I love I I like that that those you
know round of verses there let's look at
it real quick
man all right
so here we are again square square Uno
it
says which the true Spirit has brought
down I don't agree with the translation
again what do you mean you don't agree
with the
translation it's not a it's not a major
problem Al just means the the
trustworthy it has Spirit right
the trust withth you no problem it was
translated as the what was it oh yeah
true yeah it should be so the
trustworthy Spirit yeah it doesn't say
it's Gabriel
right uh
yeah you see what I'm talking about but
it's one it's one what do you mean it's
one one what
single huh it's it's it's referring to a
single entity which is is a single
entity a single entity has brought down
that's true that's true it refers to a
single entity and elsewhere it referred
to another entity and then elsewhere we
see that multiple entities come down
with the
Revelation uh okay I will tell you
why should I so my point stands no no no
no no your point is different because
the Quran itself there there are
multiple uh you could say multiple kinds
of
Revelation right
so there are Revelations like prophecies
Revelations like the book itself the
book itself which is the
Quran came only from
Gabriel other Revelations what are we
doing what are we doing look we are
talking I'm I'm G just rest it here okay
okay we saw I I understand your point
yeah your point let me just still man it
so that we all are clear and fair to you
your point is
is that according to the Quran Gabriel
brought down the Revelation the Quran
the Quran the
Quran according to another verse in the
Quran the Holy Spirit brought down the
revelation of the Quran you put two and
two together it said you Gabriel is the
Quran I mean Gabriel is the is the holy
spirit yes my contention is is that
that's not necessarily the case what
could be the conclusion and what seems
to be the conclusion from the context of
the Quran is that Gabriel and the Holy
Spirit are two different entities who
together brought down the Quran why did
we get that from because we saw that
Allah sends the angels with the spirit
to bring down the Revelation to his to
his
servants not only so we see that the
angels are distinct from the spirit and
both bring down the
Revelation so and the Revelation is not
exclusive to books no worries agree it
doesn't matter it doesn't it doesn't
matter both the spirit and the both the
spirit and the angels bring down the
Revelation together they do it together
that's what the Quran says not not
together doesn't mean all coming as a
bunch as a gang to bring down revelation
open the verse
again he brings he sends down the angels
to with the Revelation uh it doesn't say
with the Revelation it says with the
spirit please let's be honest if
interprets that the spirit is the
Revelation that's fine but let's be
honest with what it says it's
not or IB Abbas sorry
okay so IB Abbas interprets the spirit
to to be the Revelation exactly so he's
not denying that spirit means Revelation
or that's not what he's arguing he's
argues that the spirit is the Revelation
fine so the spirit The Rook is the
Revelation it's not the Angels so the
spirit and the angels they come down
together they come down together and
they speak they warn the the Servants of
Allah it doesn't say together though
what does the word with
mean what what what what does the word
with
mean do we really have to do this with
Islam I see your point thank you I see
your point but what I am arguing is that
Revelation comes down to prophets right
mhm prophets come in different times
sure therefore not all Angels come
together no whenever the revelations
come to the prophets the angels with the
spirit come and bring the Revelation
that's the point so when the Revelation
came to Muhammad the Angel and the
spirit brought down the Quran to
[Music]
Muhammad okay yes
yes okay but again I I I will restate my
argument again you're going to restate
it why okay okay I I'll tell you but
look uh he sends down the angels with
the Revelation right with the spirit
with the okay whatever with the spirit
As You
Wish uh this uh this as you said could
be interpreted as uh multiple Angels
coming in again bringing down Revelation
with the
spirit with the
spirit or it can be interpreted as
different Angels coming
down different Angels coming down this
is why they are angels with an S because
they are different is it's not
necessarily that the angels are together
it's necessarily that the Angel and
the spirit as you want to say it or as
AB said as the Quran not me as the Quran
says it right you're saying it's not the
spirit as the Quran blatantly says not
it ain't me the only thing I do is read
so okay yeah yeah I I know I know that
the only thing you you do is read I know
that's it however however we should take
a scripture as how the people of the re
the recipients interpreted right right
so we shouldn't take it for what it says
we should take it for how someone tries
to no no no no I didn't I didn't say
that I said that if a verse might
contain different meanings the meaning
you should conclude is the one that the
recipients concluded really instead of
the plain reading of the text that's in
front of my eyes I should I should I
should close my intellect close no no no
no no no no I don't say that every all
due respect every with all due respect I
know that's not what you're that's not
what you said but it's what you're
saying
I should cut off my critical thinking
cut off my reading comprehension and
just blindly follow an interpretation
from somebody so that I can just go with
what they said and then my problem
solved right nope to to interpret the
Quran you have to understand uh the
Arabic language
correct do you agree with this statement
to an
extent no it it should be 100% look
brother look to to interpret to
interpret the Quran you have to
understand the Arabic language so your
point is we get the Arabic language from
those your point is the people of the
people who give interpretation they have
a better understanding than we do we
should go with them um that I'm gonna be
real with you not only because of that
but because they also had the prophet
with them they have the prophet they
understand it they know Arabic so on and
so forth yes that that could work for
for you for me I'm a critical thinker I
have reading comprehension and I don't I
I I just that doesn't work for me if
what they say doesn't match what what
I'm blatantly reading I can't I can't
just do that you know so that's where I
am um I'm not convinced by any other
position if Ian NEOS was here I'd debate
him too and cook him but unfortunately
he's been dead for a while so but I do
appreciate you coming I do got to let
another guest come you know you're more
than welcome to come again anytime and
we can either flush this out a little
bit more or uh we'll you know talk about
something else next time uh also when
when do you use stream because Monday
Wednesdays and Fridays same time okay
okay all right you take care okay okay
all right peace